nicolás y alicia hicieron una
competencia de escalada en muro la
altura de 'alicia sobre el suelo está
dada por la ecuación a es igual a un
tercio de t más 5 donde a es la altura
de 'alicia medida en metros t es el
tiempo transcurrido desde el inicio de
la competencia en segundos
nicolás comenzó a escalar al mismo
tiempo que alicia y también lo hace con
una velocidad constante su altura sobre
el suelo en diversos momentos se ilustra
en la siguiente tabla aquí le dan el
tiempo en segundos que ha transcurrido y
esta es la altura de nicolás en metros
quien empezó la carrera en un punto más
alto del muro supongo por la pregunta
que alguno de los dos será mejor y le
dio ventaja a la otra persona o algo así
pero bueno para hacer esto para
contestar esta pregunta lo que tengo que
hacer es encontrar la altura de ambos en
el tiempo te igual a cero que fue cuando
comenzó la carrera para alice y esto es
muy fácil simplemente tengo que
sustituir aquí de igual a cero y obtengo
que la altura de 'alicia va a ser un
tercio por cero por cero más cinco un
tercio por cero es simplemente cero así
que la altura inicial de alicia era
cinco metros
es la altura inicial de 'alicia ahora
para nicolás pues podemos hacer lo
siguiente vamos a poner aquí de nuevo el
tiempo
tiempo lo voy a notar acá arriba y voy a
poner aquí n de nicolás y les parece
bien bueno y qué sé yo sé que cuando el
tiempo era de 6 segundos la altura de
nicolás era de 6 metros y que cuando el
tiempo era 8 segundos
muchos segundos la altura de nicolás era
de 7 metros también sé que cuando el
tiempo era 10 segundos entonces la
altura era 8 metros y aquí puedo inferir
lo siguiente me doy cuenta que por cada
dos segundos que pasan por cada dos
segundos que pasan aquí tengo un cambio
de un metro en la altura de nicolás aquí
otra vez pasaron dos segundos y tengo un
cambio de un metro en la altura entonces
puedo revertir este proceso y pensar
bueno si me voy dos segundos en el
pasado llegó a cuatro segundos
tendría que haber retrocedido un metro
así que de seis pasaría a cinco
recuerden aquí voy a en reversa de
cuatro también puedo pasar a dos
segundos y entonces estaría un metro más
abajo estaría en cuatro y finalmente en
cero segundos estaría a tres metros de
altura por lo tanto la altura de nicolás
sería de tres metros y sería menor que
la de galicia
ahora bien otro modo de contestar el
mismo problema es plantear una ecuación
para la altura de nicolás así como
tenemos una ecuación para la altura de
'alicia por ejemplo podría decir que la
altura de nicolás como yo sé que están
los dos escalando a una velocidad
constante donde ésta también lo hace con
velocidad constante entonces la ecuación
que describe su altura debe ser lineal y
entonces debe tener la forma en la
altura de nicolás es igual a alguna
constante m que es esencialmente la
velocidad por el tiempo que ha
transcurrido más la altura inicial de
nicolás entonces tiene s m pues va a ser
la pendiente de la línea recta que
representa la gráfica de esta ecuación o
otro mo expresar lo es m es la velocidad
a la que nicolás sube por el muro y eso
está dado por el cambio en la altura de
nicolás dividido entre el cambio en
algún intervalo de tiempo estos dos
tienen que estar ligados bien yo sé que
si el cambio en el tiempo es de dos
segundos
dos segundos entonces el cambio en la
altura de nicolás es de 1 metro es de un
metro por lo tanto nicolás está subiendo
una velocidad de un metro cada dos
segundos o que la pendiente aquí es un
medio de modo que si sustituyo esto
podría escribirlo como n es igual a m
pero m es simplemente la velocidad
nicolás que es un medio m por un medio
por t más la altura original de nicolás
cuando te era igual a cero ahora para
encontrar esta vez simplemente sustituyo
cualquiera de estas parejas de puntos
porque si este después de este tiempo
tiene que estar a esta altura por lo
tanto podría poner por ejemplo si pongo
la altura igual a 6 entonces 6 tiene que
ser igual a un medio del tiempo el
tiempo para la altura 66 segundos así
que un medio por 6 + b o lo que es lo
mismo esto es 3 + b de donde es igual
estas dos cosas y resto 3 de ambos lados
de la ecuación obtengo que b es igual a
3 de donde la ecuación de la altura de
nicolás sería m es igual a
un medio del tiempo transcurrido más
tres y si pongo aquí te igual a cero
obtengo que la altura original de
nicolás en el muro era de tres metros
así que quien estaba más alto en el muro
tiene empezar la carrera en un punto más
alto del muro pues fue alicia así que la
segunda opción es la correcta